Poco después de que llegara a la oficina
del fiscal general de Nueva York para
ser interrogado Donald Trump emitió un
comunicado diciendo que no tenía otra
opción que invocar la quinta enmienda
decliné a responder a las preguntas en
virtud de los derechos y privilegios que
la Constitución de Estados Unidos otorga
a todo ciudadano el ex presidente
estadounidense es objeto de una
investigación civil sobre más de una
década de irregularidades financieras la
organización Trump la multimillonaria
empresa que gestiona hoteles campos de
golf y otras propiedades inmobiliarias
la fiscal general de Nueva York Leticia
James ha citado importantes pruebas
contra el conglomerado familiar que está
bajo la lupa por proporcionar
información engañosa sobre sus activos a
las autoridades para obtener préstamos y
beneficios Fiscales Esta no es la única
medida legal en curso contra el
expresidente la oficina del fiscal de
distrito de Manhattan está llevando a
cabo una investigación paralela en la
organización Trump que tiene el
potencial de imputar cargos criminales
Mientras tanto de Mara lago fue
registrada por el FBI el lunes en una
investigación Federal separada sobre si
retiró ilegalmente documentos
clasificados de la Casa Blanca cuando
dejó el cargo En enero de 2021 Trump ha
negado cualquier delito ya calificado
las pesquisas de tener motivación
política de Cara a su posible
candidatura presidencial de 2024